the following contains discussion of
graphic murder and rape viewer
discretion is advised
at first a single investigator worked
the case full time now several people
are involved
the pressure to catch this man has been
mounting white male 6 feet tall weighing
185 pounds tying up husbands or male
companions she was bound he raped her
when it happened in 1980 it was a murder
in a small town it was a sensational
god-awful murder in a small town lyman
smith was a 43 year old attorney about
to be appointed a state judge by
california governor jerry brown his wife
charlene smith was a 33 year old
interior decorator they were found in
their bedroom bound and bludgeoned to
death with a log from the fireplace
charlene had also been raped there was a
lot of reason why you would think that
someone they knew did this and it had a
lot of feeling and emotion behind it
lyman smith's daughter jennifer carroll
had just graduated from high school i
didn't necessarily believe i would be
next on his list but i did have a fear
that
there could still be somebody out there
and that i
knew that he watched and that he wasn't
past
catching up with prior victims that was
part of his mo was to call people from
the past or to be basically a terrorist
detectives were flummoxed but they did
collect a semen sample belonging to the
killer in 1980 the technology necessary
to match the dna sample left at the
crime scene with the killer didn't exist
38 years after lyman and charlene smith
were murdered investigators tracked a
suspect to a hobby lobby craft store in
roseville california collecting dna from
his car door handle while he was inside
later they pulled another sample from a
tissue found in his home trash the
sample matched the dna that had been
collected from the smith crime scene
tuesday sacramento county sheriff's
deputies arrested joseph james deangelo
at his home in citrus heights i get
chills just thinking about it you know
it's true you can see it with your own
eyes but there's no way it could be true
police had finally tracked down the
golden state killer using a new tool in
crime fighting an online genealogy
database he did leave behind his genetic
code the final piece of the puzzle for
sacramento county district attorney anne
marie schubert and her investigators i
believe very strongly that it's the
greatest tool ever given to law
enforcement the golden state killer's
capture became a sensation in magazines
newspapers books podcasts television
shows and an hbo series but the methods
used to catch d'angelo also meant
digging through the lives of a
significant portion of his family tree
it's revealing the information of
everyone else related to them close or
distantly presenting profound
implications for constitutional rights
of privacy we have to revisit the legal
doctrines that apply the kind of data
sifted through to find the golden state
killer may be the most personal to ever
come along and the most difficult for an
individual to control putting secrets
about our family health and biological
future in the hands of powerful entities
they can start testing for things that
we can't even conceive of today the
capture of the golden state killer was
the culmination of a technological big
data movement that has been growing
since the turn of the century without
many of the traditional legal safeguards
for privacy the methods used to catch
the golden state killer made it
significantly easier to find suspects in
horrendous cases but it may be just as
easy for the government to track
innocent citizens via their dna
[Music]
you know it's 1980 and i was just 18 and
i had graduated high school early and
i'm very grateful because the folks at
buena high let me come back and hang out
there problem solving around that my dad
had been murdered and charlene had been
murdered but also
just figuring out a way to insulate
myself from the kind of madness that was
going on a small town double murder not
only confounded investigators but the
entire ventura california community but
jennifer carroll felt supported by the
people around her as years dragged on
without any charges in the case i've
always had bells on my exterior doors so
i could hear if somebody's coming or
going i've always slept with an oakland
a's mini bat even though i'm also a
giants fan but i had an oakland a's mini
bat and then i've always kept a bottle
of perfume by my bed i would be willing
to fight to the death to protect my home
and myself
before i would just give up an acquiesce
as leads in the smith case went cold a
new tool in crime fighting was beginning
to turn the criminal justice system
upside down dna evidence is now used
with such frequency that genetic
fingerprinting has become routine
in the late 1980s before the advent of
genealogical databases and crime
fighting dna samples from crime scenes
had to be large in quantity to be tested
meaning big pools of blood or large
quantities of semen or saliva back then
samples were manually analyzed and
required a lot of analysis the way
someone might look at an out-of-focus
photograph and try to interpret what
they see this new scientific tool was
enough to upend the criminal justice
system allowing investigators to catch
perpetrators and exonerate the innocent
in 1994 the federal government created a
database called the combined dna index
system or codis before the system could
launch the fbi had to come up with
standards for what level of detail to
store in the database erin murphy is a
former public defender and the author of
inside the cell the dark side of
forensic dna there's this need to
develop a dna profile that is
discriminating enough among people to
identify them but not so discriminating
that it invades their privacy or costs
too much to do law enforcement decided
on a portion of the genome just 13
places at the time they each have two
pieces of information one for mom one
from dad so that means you'll have
essentially 26 discrete pieces of
information part of the benefit of that
method is that it doesn't really tell
you very much about someone's health or
their physical characteristics or
anything like that regions that are
non-coding don't don't signify anything
that's where you get this idea of junk
it's just junk dna that stays and is
still the mainstay of dna testing as the
turn of the century came police thought
dna matches would be the future of
solving the most heinous crimes
[Music]
investigators from counties up and down
california were investigating what
seemed to be rapes and murders contained
to their own communities from the 1970s
on though there was some speculation
that they could be connected in 2000 my
daughter was
pretty young new she was about a year
old we were going back down to ventura
to visit old friends and show off the
kid and that sort of thing and i thought
i'm going to stop by the police
department just see if there's been any
progress it's been 20 years has there
been something
and the man i went in to see the officer
that i saw said i think you need to sit
down okay that's
a little condescending and i said yeah
probably not and then he said well
your dad's murder has been linked to a
set of
other murders in southern california we
believe he's the victim of a serial
killer
yeah i did need to sit down
investigators couldn't find a match in
the fbi's codis database but they did
find matches between a series of rapes
and killings across southern california
then an even bigger revelation it was
just a couple years later i was driving
here in the bay area and listening to
kgo and i heard them announced that a
series of rapes in northern california
had been connected with murders in
southern california and my intuition
just said i bet that's us the killer's
mayhem was more widespread than anyone
had thought oh hell yes dna connected
all of them and that for me
was everything to me i almost felt like
we had caught him without knowing who it
was but i knew when we got the person
whose dna matched we were done police
believe the same individual was
responsible for at least 10 murders and
44 rapes up and down the state and the
total number grew from there the
revelation of a serial killer seemed
like it was just a matter of time before
police would find the suspect in a law
enforcement database little did they
know that it would be a completely
different dna database developed outside
of law enforcement that would lead to
the front steps of the killer the
eventual search would be so potentially
shocking to the public that
investigators would lie about what they
did for years
[Laughter]
[Music]
the human genome project has no lesser
goal than to map every bit of
information contained in the human
genetic blueprint in 1990 the human
genome project promised to map the
entire genetic makeup of the human body
for 3 billion within 15 years while the
task had to be completed manually in the
beginning the project got ahead of its
time horizon after the arrival of
automated dna sequencers by 2001 there
was a working draft of almost the entire
genome in coming years doctors
increasingly will be able to cure
diseases like alzheimer's parkinson's
diabetes and cancer
by attacking their genetic roots
[Music]
the genetic basis for most diseases
turned out to be far more complicated
than scientists had assumed but the
technology did create a brand new market
for consumer genetic testing
ancestry.com announced that it was
teaming up with a genetics lab to offer
you a handy-dandy home dna test kit
there was an opportunity to gather
information about people which they
could monetize i analogize it to
facebook or instagram or twitter vika
barlow studied genetics and
developmental biology before becoming an
attorney specializing in dna cases you
are being provided the service in an
exchange you give them all of your
genetic data advances in technology now
make dna testing affordable for anyone
some call it genealogy to the extreme
it's dna testing new startups promise to
let customers understand their familial
roots in ways they never had before i
used a sperm donor to have my daughter
so dna is a big part of our life
don't know much about him other than
what he shared as part of the sperm bank
information and i thought it would be
really helpful to understand what
markers might come up if we use 23andme
i think there's real value in people
being able to learn about themselves and
being able to manage their health and
manage procreation by having dna
information that can help them make
informed choices a lot of people have
found that they're carriers for things
like cystic fibrosis and they had no
idea okay so you call this well this is
a spit party a spit party spit party in
the spit lounge guests provided a sample
of their dna for decoding the spit
collectors work for a website called
23 and me it's like looking in the
mirror for the first time if you've
never looked in the mirror before
you would want to look it's actually
looking for things that
we as consumers
really have no grasp of what they are at
this moment and that can change
they can start testing for things that
we can't even conceive of today
[Music]
while the fbi's dna database tested for
a teeny tiny portion of the genome these
companies were testing for much more
it's a huge amount of genetic
information it's also a different kind
of genetic information it's not this
junk useless stuff it's the key to all
of these questions people want to answer
through genomics companies like ancestry
etc use a method that's known as snips
single nucleotide polymorphism and when
they're looking at these snips they're
not looking at
13 places 20 places they're not looking
at a thousand of these snips they're
looking at hundreds of thousands
millions companies encouraged customers
to compare their results online the
genealogy industry experienced a
renaissance with conferences
community-run facebook groups podcasts
and youtube how-to's by 2018 23andme had
collected the dna of 10 million users
ancestry.com had 15 million smaller
companies like myheritage dna and family
tree dna also collected profiles many
users downloaded their raw genetic data
and uploaded it to an open source
website called jet match
by 2013 investigators across california
had started calling their suspect the
golden state killer but dna collected
from the crime scenes didn't produce a
match when checked against law
enforcement databases when genealogy
companies started gaining traction
investigators took notice perhaps the
golden state killer or more likely a
family member had willingly handed over
the dna code of their family tree
detectives began to dig with the help of
barbara ray venter gedmatch.com seemed
like a particularly useful resource
because anyone could upload analyzed or
genotyped dna data to check for
comparisons what happened next would be
retold to newspapers tv programs
podcasts an hbo documentary and victims
rights groups law enforcement says they
were able to link this dna using an open
source genealogy website called jed man
dead match jed match
it turns out that story wasn't true
federal and local law enforcement
conducted a much more invasive and
widespread search than was originally
thought tiptoeing around privacy
policies and misleading the public with
a story about ged match their path to
finding the killer shows why guidelines
for law enforcement to respect the civil
liberties of citizens is important
without them they could make up the
rules as they go which is exactly what
happened
we've had the golden state killer's dna
up in codis since 2001 no hits we've
done familial searches here in
california every single year in which
it's been legal no hit we've done
international searches we
did everything without success paul holz
was the longtime investigator of the
golden state killer case he was the one
who saw opportunity in the blossoming
world of online genealogy databases the
old form or the classic form of forensic
testing is like taking a picture of
someone's house and the new form is
moving in it's just living there it's
squatting forever genetic genealogy
isn't just revealing the information of
the person who shared their genome it's
revealing the information of everyone
else related to them close or distantly
according to a 2018 report in the
journal science in the near future
anyone of european descent could be
identified through genealogical
databases because of the ability to
infer familial relationships a lot of
people don't consent they're now
basically discoverable and that's just
not how we've operated in this country
that's why we have the fourth amendment
it's because we value privacy 23andme
and ancestry.com had promised to protect
their customers privacy stating that
they would only provide information to
the government under a court order and
they published transparency reports
about the police requests they received
there was no way to analyze the golden
state killer's dna without the company's
consent customers are asked to submit
plastic vials full of saliva
in february 2018 barbara ray venter the
genealogist assisting the fbi uploaded
the killer's genetic data to an online
dna database and that search gave her
the names of a series of second cousins
filling out the family tree she was
constructing and ultimately leading
police to the killer all the people who
are in the golden state killer's family
tree outside of that immediate family
they have no idea that was them they
were the one it's their family tree that
is now sitting on a hard drive somewhere
in a computer in california or their
personal financial history records et
cetera birth records death records
marriage records that are sitting in a
folder labeled gsk investigation fenter
was able to narrow down the suspect to
six people one had blue eyes matching
the description many gave of the golden
state killer a man who terrorized
neighborhoods throughout california
during a raping and killing spree in the
70s and 80s may now be in custody i
don't even think i ate that day was
until the end of the day that the
emotions really flooded in
and you feel relief and horror
and
compassion and too many feelings at once
it's almost like crashing feelings
[Music]
according to the los angeles times it
was myheritage a privately owned dna
database reventor used that provided the
head that would find the killer unlike
ancestry or 23andme myheritage allowed
customers to upload genetic data
generated by third parties for analysis
on its site so venter was able to upload
d'angelo's data which had been genotyped
by police and pretend it was her own jed
match a genealogy side being credited as
the missing key but investigators had
claimed that ray venter had tracked down
d'angelo using jet match an open source
genealogy database so why did they lie
the fbi told sacramento investigators to
keep the involvement of myheritage a
secret saying they needed to protect the
names of confidential sources holst told
the los angeles times we were entirely
confident that it would pass legal
muster but we understood that there
could be a fallout in terms of public
perception
the search of my heritage existed in a
legal gray area while the privacy policy
assured users that their information
would only be released if required by
law it also didn't account for a covert
genealogical law enforcement search the
company didn't even know the search had
happened until late 2020 law
enforcement's willingness to mislead the
public afterward points to an
uncertainty that the public will ever
know all the details about these types
of searches according to the times
report many different databases were
used up until the myheritage hit
including y search jet match and the
private site family tree dna which
willingly ignored their privacy policy
so police could search their database
without a warrant searching through
multiple databases on their way to
finding joseph d'angelo meant
investigators may have come into contact
with the lives of possibly thousands of
innocent people considering the mapping
of family trees over a long period of
time across multiple dna databases
you're going through the lives of
thousands of people to find your guy
rifling through the lives of thousands
of innocent people people you know are
not the perpetrator of the crime is a
pretty serious thing to
encourage law enforcement to do the
methods used to catch d'angelo invert
the traditional approach to search and
seizure as sanctioned by the
constitution the idea is not that police
are supposed to indiscriminately kind of
rummage through the lives of citizens
looking for crime they're supposed to
have probable cause targeted suspicion
to believe somebody's involved in
criminal activity and then from that
suspicion perhaps develop reason for
arrest or prosecution the fbi and local
investigators have always maintained
that what they were doing was within
legal bounds
the rest of the golden state killer led
to an explosion in the use of
genealogical databases as a
crime-fighting tool but the practice may
violate the privacy of many individuals
found along the way to finding a suspect
the rest of the golden state killer was
a triumph of justice but it also
emboldened investigators and could
easily be abused in the years to come
i've thought a lot about dna because of
course it was responsible for his arrest
and i had banked on it for years decades
knowing that that's how we would catch
the bad guy
at the same time i feel like i straddle
this ethical chasm because
dna is probably the only thing that if i
choose to share it is not just my
privacy that i am giving up i'm kind of
regretting that i put my kid on 23andme
because
now based on what's happened i kind of
wish i had waited with her so she could
make her own decisions about that it's
interesting because yes i've lived with
dna my whole life not knowing what i'm
getting or what i am getting
[Music]
civil liberties advocates worry about
the uncertain future of using dna
databases combined with sensitive dna
testing changing the traditional ways
investigations are brought about when
dna first entered the criminal justice
system large quantities of dna were
needed for testing traditionally it was
big blood stains that were being tested
so you knew what you were looking at you
knew there was a story behind a stain
like that but now we're testing things
that have no necessary relevance to a
crime dna methodology has always been
moving towards more sensitive test
methods these tiny samples are called
touch dna they could look for things
that people had touched because the
theory is that what we touch
we leave some of our dna behind on
humans shed dna wherever they go and at
varying rates as well meaning a killer's
dna may end up on the murder weapon or
they may never leave a trace conversely
an innocent person might have marginally
come in contact with a murder weapon and
shed a lot of dna on it you can get
cells that belong to people who may not
have ever even come in contact with that
item they might have come in contact
with another person who came into
contact with that item or they might
have walked by and sneezed near that
item but they never actually physically
touched the item crime scene samples can
often be mixtures of multiple people's
dna making it hard to decipher so the
result of that is that there can be
sort of so much information in the
sample because it's so many different
people's dna that you can start to kind
of see what you want to see similarly a
sample may be of such low quality and
quantity that it may not be a full
profile and when you only have part of
the sample that ability to kind of
rorschach test it to see what you want
to see is even greater this problem is
particularly acute given the growth in
dna databases without a dna database if
you have a sample from a crime scene and
you want to match it to a perpetrator
you need circumstantial evidence
suggesting someone may be responsible
perhaps they were seen near the crime
scene on video or there was a history of
violence with the dna database the
temptation for prosecutors is to find a
match in the database and work backwards
if you have 17 million people's dna and
you're doing this kind of rorschach
testing you s sort of have this huge
pool of people to suspect and often
there will be no other evidence or often
the other evidence will be kind of
accumulated later and although it might
support
the finding of guilt like oh they live
in the same state or oh you know they
have a prior record of some kind really
what you're doing is you're saying this
partial profile matches and that's what
i'm kind of building the scaffold of the
case on and these other coincidental
factors just help support my finding and
so databases make that ambiguous quality
of some of these samples much more
potentially pernicious because they
allow police to take those incomplete
samples and sort of find perpetrators
who seem to match but may in fact not be
the actual perpetrator of the crime
and we will all see
the unbelievable capacity
of humanity to be noble
this is a great day
thank you very much
as the human genome project was coming
to a close scientists worried about the
possibilities of being able to quickly
sequence genes today in the wake of the
golden state killer's capture
genealogical databases have also forced
us to confront the possibilities of
allowing the government to know so much
about citizens biological makeup without
any guidelines but the dark turn of dna
collection and databasing has already
begun while dna can catch serial killers
it can also be used against citizens in
horrific ways
while u.s law enforcement was trying to
catch the golden state killer chinese
law enforcement began to collect the dna
of its population to crack down on
future crimes the act is a lesson in
what's possible in a world where the
government has few restrictions on how
they can use dna databases as well as
the larger role biotech companies have
begun to play in law enforcement all
over the world
[Music]
in china a group of minority muslims
called uyghurs were targeted by police
in the dna dragnet in the 1990s after
the soviet union fell uyghurs outside of
china saw liberation in places like
uzbekistan and kazakhstan but uyghurs in
china's xinjiang province did not as
uyghurs in china began to protest
beijing began to see them as a threat to
statehood and met the resistance with
violent retaliation in recent years the
widgets have been the victims of
discrimination and any protest has been
swiftly crushed over the next 25 years
chinese police took a proactive approach
to controlling weakers using technology
uyghur saw their lives become a living
surveillance state full of cameras
tracking their every move police
checkpoints and key cards that
controlled where they could travel
software that monitored messages on
their phones and a grading system that
determined how often they would receive
visits from the police at home beijing
also put uighurs in work and
re-education camps and blamed the entire
population for the acts of extremist
terrorists today it's not uncommon for
reakers to disappear without a word to
family members some weakers are never
heard from again
now with dna chinese law enforcement has
begun sorting uyghurs and other
minorities by their ethnicity under the
guise of preventing future crimes the
information could help authorities
dramatically tighten their control over
uighurs lives excluding them from public
education and healthcare forcing them to
live in ghettos or sending them to
internment camps based on their genetic
makeup in a world where dna technology
is rapidly revealing information about
health genealogical makeup as well as
information that leads to the capture of
notorious criminals like the golden
state killer it's also giving us a world
where authoritarian regimes can even
more effectively succumb to horrific
impulses when you see it in terms of
this constant
surveillance thing that's around your
head
then it's very powerful because it tells
you we know everything you're doing you
know you you are we kind of know what
you're thinking i type something on on
the internet i have to worry who's
reading this i'm calling someone i have
to worry who's listening all these
issues even if they're not real even if
it's not happening you can feel how that
makes this machine that controls people
eve monroe is a professor who studies
human clinical genomics at the
university of leuven in belgium so we
think that it's all law enforcement
wanting more and more toys in fact when
you look deeper you see something much
more complicated after a terrorist
attack in 2014 chinese law enforcement
began to use pre-emptive efforts in
xinjiang an autonomous territory in
northwest china populated by uyghurs
what seemed to have happened is that in
2014 the chinese government panicked and
then they went full force against the
entire population to contain a potential
theorist thread that was really quite
minor obviously there was some
separatist ideas there was a bit of
muslim radicalism not more so than what
we for example see in some parts of
europe but they panicked and they said
we have to change this according to the
ngo human rights watch xinjiang
authorities collected fingerprints iris
scans blood types and dna samples from
all residents between the ages of 12 and
65. biological samples blood in
particular was collected in a way that
was actually suitable for dna profiling
the dna profile seems to be on the lower
end of places on the genome however
these samples they remain available so
as technology progresses nothing
prevents
five years from now to re-running all
these biological samples potentially
with new technology chinese police
bought equipment and had technology
tailored for them by a u.s company named
thermo fisher scientific one of the
world's leading makers of dna technology
for law enforcement all over the world
including the united states the huaxa
platinum system tailored for chinese
police could effectively identify
chinese ethnic groups scientists from
thermo fisher scientific and the
people's public security university of
china which works under chinese law
enforcement talked about how successful
the technology was in a 2016 scientific
reports paper published by the nature
research journal noting it was effective
at investigating if a dna sample
belonged to someone of han tibetan or
uyghur descent every citizen knows oh my
dna is there people are very concerned
about defining ethnicity so putting you
in bins saying you belong to this family
we don't like that family this is not
possible telling you you're a real ugo
or you're halfway or you're not this dna
database can do that in 2019 thermo
fisher scientific said it would stop
selling dna sequencers in xinjiang after
pressure built up over years from human
rights groups and politicians but the
company's work with chinese law
enforcement extended beyond xinjiang a
june 2020 report from the australian
strategic policy institute detailed that
since 2017 the company along with dozens
of chinese companies also helped china's
ministry of public security expand its
dna dragnet across china authorities
collected saliva and blood samples from
men and boys who are thought to be most
likely to commit the majority of crimes
and they're deploying this database
across the entire country so now they
are just a couple years away from having
a dna database that would cover the
entire male population of china chinese
police have said citizens hand over
their dna voluntarily but human rights
groups have scoffed at the suggestion
thermo fisher scientific did not respond
to our interview request but the
australian report estimates that the
chinese government has access to
somewhere between 100 million and 140
million profiles making it the largest
dna database in the world
it may seem like a fantasy for any
country to entertain the idea of a
universal dna database of people on the
scale of what's happening in china but
in a world where even just a portion of
the population is available to law
enforcement through the invasive testing
done by genealogy companies police could
simply infer familial relationships
sending the united states barreling
towards a future where everyone may be
identifiable by the government adding a
pair of surveillance eyes to law
enforcement's arsenal that go far beyond
data collection of what you think do or
say it's a future where the government
could expand their power to control
human behavior targeting people over
perceived bad genes going after
genetically linked families deemed to be
unfavorable by an administration
exposing secrets about health and family
lineage when privacy stops being a
social norm authoritarian power slowly
creeps in
[Music]
detectives in the golden state killer
case entered the 21st century seeking to
bring justice to victims families with
cutting-edge dna technology they thought
they could do it themselves by searching
the combined dna index system codis a
law enforcement database of people
linked to the criminal justice system
but a private online dna database would
end up providing the clue that would
lead to the killer a cousin's genetic
code was close enough to the lyman and
charlene smith crime scene dna left by
the golden state killer d'angelo
eventually said he was guilty in late
2020. yesterday in sacramento a 74 year
old retired mechanic and former police
officer
admitted to being the serial rapist and
murderer his name is joseph d'angelo jr
and he pleaded guilty to 13
murders and rapes the suspects became
known as the golden state killer the new
method in crime fighting went on to be
used to name suspects in dozens of other
cold cases across the united states
ushering in a new technological leap
that the law is still catching up with
there's been through our history
moments in time where technology
develops it just changes the way the
world works so fundamentally that we
have to revisit the legal doctrines that
apply and i think we're in one of those
inflection points as regards technology
year after year scientists discover new
details about dna sometimes in the most
surprising ways it's still an evolving
technology that we don't really know
what it holds but we do have some in
disha of what's there and i think we
have to say is total genetic
transparency by law enforcement really
something we should tolerate in our
society even at the expense of not
catching
all crime or even stopping some of the
most serious crime lawmakers could
restrict the scope of searches so they
aren't as intrusive some of the
standards required for a sample's
inclusion in the fbi's combined dna
index system may be a helpful path for
the lack of genetic genealogy rules the
u.s has for law enforcement so the rules
and restrictions that govern the quality
and type of samples that are allowed to
be uploaded into the national database
would be in essence applied to genetic
genealogy in this way you're not going
to be able to do genetic genealogy
sample to find the witness of a crime as
opposed to the actual perpetrator you
can't do it in a laboratory that isn't
qualified and validated to do the kind
of testing they're claiming they do they
should be limited to the most serious
kinds of cases and they should only be
allowed to be engaged by qualified and
trained personnel
and they should be limited to crime
scene samples that were first
tested and checked against the national
forensic database basic common sense
restrictions on how it's done
big data has guided humanity into new
more efficient ways of living since the
turn of the century but it's also given
us a world where law enforcement is that
much closer to our daily habits
whereabouts and at least when it comes
to dna our genetic makeup this big data
movement this technological moment in
time really requires rethinking these
fundamental questions about how people
and the police relate we can't move
through the world keeping ourselves from
shedding dna and more importantly we
can't stop other people to whom we're
related
so distantly we may not even know them
from making decisions about genetic
transparency that are different from the
ones that we would make and so i think
the law needs to come to recognize that
the genome in its enduring quality its
infancy we don't know exactly what the
genomes secrets will tell us that it's a
different kind of piece of information
that deserves better protection both
from the decision making of your you
know relatives and also from prying
police eyes maryland has a bill on the
governor's desk that limits the use of
genetic genealogy by police to serious
crimes and requires police to ask a
judge's permission before it begins a
search it may be a framework other
states will look to
joseph james d'angelo was convicted of
13 murders and 50 rapes and he'll spend
the rest of his life in prison as a part
of a plea agreement to avoid the death
penalty as a part of the agreement he
admitted to committing more rapes where
the statute of limitations had run out
i suspect there's a function of age
involved but it has made me remember a
lot of things i'd forgotten or put away
for whatever reason if you had asked me
when i was 18 when they catch the guy
will this change your life i would have
thought no it has no impact on me and in
fact maybe because it's been 38 years
it's had a tremendous impact